well a high profile visit from the u.s
agriculture secretary's office
here in southern nevada officials are
checking out how summer feeding programs
are working out in local schools hector
mejia reports
hey there well secretary vilsack is
making stops at a number of communities
across the country today it was
henderson's turn here at mcdonald
elementary where that tour happened
during lunch service
and we've learned one in four students
here in clark county are food insecure
meaning
they don't often know where their next
meal will come from
u.s agriculture secretary tom vilsack
said the american rescue plan
created a summer feeding program but
it's only for a year and there's now
push to make it a permanent program
so today he met with governor steve
sisilak along with u.s congresswoman
susie lee
they went over the biden
administration's goal to promote healthy
eating
and how the american family's plan will
help achieve that goal
it is an issue of food security it is
also an issue of nutrition
and what we saw today here at mcdonald's
school
is a commitment to both making sure that
youngsters are fed even during a
pandemic
millions of meals but also making sure
that they're fed well
the carrots the apple slices
good snacks quality snacks for
youngsters here in clark county as many
as three out of four students
qualify for free or reduced lunches and
the secretary also talked about the
president's
infrastructure plan and how they're
working to pass a bipartisan package
to get the economy moving faster we are
in henderson this afternoon hector mejia
8 news now